hello and welcome to this rapid game
then I'm going to open with what exactly
do I do 9 f3
let's go 9 f3 my usual default move yeah
I hope the video is recording alright I
had some changes with the xsplit
software so I sincerely hope everything
is ok
I somehow the webcam it looks a bit
weird like I'm and it's kind of right
everything I had to know what that is
yeah but anyway you know how I look like
so nothing special
ok so I'm playing against pad 6 5 7 8
and let's see a Queen's Indian style
position it's still well a very flexible
black can play a number of setups with
c5 he would turn the a transpose into
possibly Hedgehog formation now Bishop
e7 is a Queen's Indian Queen's Indian
style position I think I've not let not
played before yet so this is a bit
different compared to the regular
convinient when they are black
oftentimes has 94 available the e4
square this is not the case with white
delaying deform it takes a really long
time here - bit surprising it is 15 plus
5 by the way usually I go 15 plus 3 but
you challenged me to 15 plus 5 it
I think I really welcome one or two
extra extra seconds it's certainly okay
not a big difference anyhow that's too
long really for such a reasonably simple
decision here if you play six b6 you
should know what to do here by the way
to move that is playable but rarely
played is the move g6 it's a little bit
it looks a little bit strange but it is
perfectly okay g6 Bishop Bishop g7 it
usually leads to more a little bit more
imbalance positions I go I went for b3
Bishop b2 and White has three main
choices he can do get exactly what I did
take Adam and we can go Knight c3 rook
e1 trying to play me for I'll just play
d4 to transpose back into the Queen's in
Ian yeah with c5 we again transpose to
something that could be easily a
hedgehog now a six or d6 signals black
Sun would signal likes intention to go
for the hedgehog you place the fire
forever yeah this is of course possible
III years the most the most and
combative option I think I can also take
but in this particular situation taking
them in the night I think you should be
fine for him so I'll go with with III
III has a couple of ideas one idea is to
have the e2 square available for the
Queen
so that Queen e2 connects looks
reasonably harmonious you towards the
square it's often pretty nice for the
Queen when both bishops are fake head
out um
there are also some direct ideas in the
center for example in some cases I'm
able to play deform and get to a hanging
pour information in the center this
hanging pour information after for them
before and kept oh sorry it was wrong
before and then you have those captures
when at the end white is stuck with C
for D for hanging pawns this hanging
pawned version can become extremely
sharp because why it has both bishops C
and Cairo which is very aggressive in
such a situation with the hand points so
quickly fives are often an option I
think I should get rid of the arrows and
the other idea then White has here is to
play something like 20 to hook a to d1
move the knight on f3 and then play with
f4 that's something that is quite sharp
we'll see what he does I think he spends
a bit too much time on
reasonably simple decisions I mean here
the only thing you can think of as well
you have three things you can take on c4
immediately all you have yeah you can
think of 96 97 yeah those two and I
think you should decide on that somewhat
quicker not be7 for example cannot be
bad here
I think 96 you have children there is
some calculation they are 96 CD 590 590
525 d4 is an interesting line
and there are even some men Queen
sacrifice as possible yeah this is this
is the situation and now I can take C
takes Knight takes Knight takes Queen
takes D form C takes Knight takes Queen
G to check King takes Knight takes d4
check this is not quite enough
compensation but it looks funny line I
can't just go Queenie to it but but I
think I will take I'm sorry my voice is
a little bit off we talked about hanging
pawns
if black note takes with the e pawn
after d4
I should have a pretty pretty favorable
hanging porn situation yeah this should
also be quite favorable the the problem
that black has is that the CC a kettle
is a really really good setup against
the hanging pawns it's very difficult to
push them forward and in this particular
case the knight on c6 is also misplaced
the night
normally belongs to d7 potentially have
six to lend more protection we'll see
what happens here Bishop f6 is an option
for black that at least prevents me from
taking on c5 immediately Queen d2 is a
normal recipe here to cover b2 and allow
recaptures with pieces on d4 so
not going to yeah you small-time I think
here the simple threat that I have is D
takes e5 d takes e5 we should be - Queen
B to be c5 rook c1 and pawn is almost
gone I can attack it with Lucchesi one
potentially Queen a3 will be difficult
to cover this point C takes D for now
for black after Knight takes d4 is
pretty awkward that's a very passive iqp
position not mean not lost or anything
but it is really uncomfortable
a little bit uncertain of black sugar
here c4
they're c4 it's tough to believe I can
probably take on c4 and play a form to
make b5 more difficult the pawn c4
should be a liability even though now
I'm like black like a suffering here
already quite a bit not so sure from 96
years such a good choice I think 9b d7
or take knight c6 is what they usually
do them
sighs I'm I know
okay so
[Music]
yeah look to see wanna is the most
obvious choice yeah just just this one
this is also keeping this is also
keeping open the possible to just play
Bishop a3 in some cases if you place
let's say okay c8 then Bishop a 3sm yeah
is a consideration
okay c8 bishop a three-night before tea
cakes B takes rook c5 should win a pawn
I think wins the C pawn okay yeah this
is interesting after D takes e5 maybe d4
Oh
it's still hard to believe that it
should work so let's take this yeah my
intention was just Queens III just try
to just try to win it
boys extremely simplistic idea but might
just work
and before I consult just take it
the moment the c-54 drops d5 will also
become a lot weaker and it's still not
certain like deform Quincy five Quincy
five rook c5 d take z3 if there is maybe
some kind of counter play but I really
don't see it I don't see anything
don't see how telling capacitors we
don't night before but I still just take
the pollen you can take a two but the
resulting structure is just pretty awful
and I think I have some text again night
before Quincy 5:25 rook c5 Knight a to
hook a one night before to b5 may be
attacking bishop end night should win
some material so we have this is
interesting
yagi one on Luke d1
one naked still not still a lot coverage
weekly one looks no more normal but
especially to hear avid okay rook d2
takes takes d5 is just hanging them
okay look after you one night before
Quincy 5:25 book c5 and also just not
worker so put it in it's more logical
than look everyone yeah this is possible
but after 94 I should have a really nice
position maybe 95
let's think about this for just a moment
it's not the night move we'll attack d5
that defaulter takes the night so what
is he going to play 95 most likely am i
have Knight f5 but then it doesn't do
all that much now finds one disadvantage
it does not attack the pawn immediately
if I go night h4 I will directly attack
the pawn
what does he come right in the first
place a problem has to play that we knew
six it is more
that isn't even so convincing
interesting the other 94 there is 95 and
oh that isn't so clear
hmm quite amazing
if I take it
be take the details I don't have a good
night jump
be tasty tx-94 you can just take on
deform
I don't I'm not really convinced that I
better understand the position if it
looks looks a bit like a missing stuff
[Music]
MP takes the cheeks is not really doing
much Oh
so if I've shown ever problem with my
keyboard saw it detaches itself or to it
then USB a really recognize that again
is very strange how I don't see a good
move I actually like to double but I
wonder if this is just lazy chairs I
grouped it to explain now I mean that's
a bit well what I did now is not really
great ever stared this for three minutes
and then play move that I haven't
considered all that correlated some all
the directs move some didn't didn't seem
to let all that much
maybe night before is annoying for who
night jumps and I'm probably not
yeah I expected that
just like before movies kind of
irritating can still probably just take
this Pontiac screen shakes night before
I think I can just take B takes c4 and
he goes for it
I mean context you cannot recapture with
the pawn which is clear and I take a
couple of times on the aid and that will
be fun
so B takes bishop chicks
I thought create three of them would be
good it was my my idea when I went for
this I think it is okay
again context group the Educare 28 queen
bee 421 check
I have queenie one saves the crank yeah
so he utterly had to do that now
it says something really good tween 83
was my was my intention
so I think I'll go them build up this
pin it's quite annoying I think okay so
he got rid of that one
however now night if I wore who could be
two there's a five here yes given
himself up chin to play five yeah the
night is five is threatening to take on
C form but not much else
I don't know if I do that if it helps
not it doesn't doesn't do all that much
nice d4 is the more static move the
night you know I should actually attack
stuff and go to a forum but I don't I
don't see how I can get there 95 there
is no way to get you
yeah again 95 I don't see what did
threatens I mean I see what it threatens
but he he has a couple of things what
does he do actually move they look the
DA talk to me aid or something I don't
want to take and give him the pass are
headed that looks downright weird not
really happy
just don't get therefore here maybe look
be to a five-night be three try to force
a trade
it took some three ed to be honest looks
a bit doesn't have doesn't look very
ammonius that's what I'm trying to say
okay six that idea
okay rook takes Bishop takes Queen takes
Queen c1 check so to take them okay now
Knight d5
it's not easy fun where does it go with
this thing 97 is also on the cards
whoopty 7 maybe but that is a shaky
looking move in fact I can take maybe
the 55 bishop and it gives me the corn
unless there is a track this one which
it is which would take the rook checks
is good Bishop takes rook the age here I
can still check it
signe would take c5 now Bitcoin
I can still do it it's so it's still a
background check made and it helped
technically a lot I think the position
was probably close to winning anyhow one
point is that the night was having this
d4 square Oh
even without them this blunder I think
is going to be very difficult for him to
hold and let's have a look so we had
this my cheeks red cheeks Yaqui cheeks
is a well-known theoretical line we can
you do that request analysis and I think
therefore there is some funny idea there
says there are some ideas with the Queen
sacrifice I think actually that and if
black does this this is not not a clear
thing if I'm not mistaken this is not
entirely clear I mean the the engine
things wide wins that file they know
this is not totally wrong one mid one
wonder and kind of curious where
okay well I think that normally goes
back and then this is a bit better for
white okay each up with the pawn I go
deform should have six when you talk
when you're seven looks you want very
normal and now I take take take
Quincy 3d and so it looks old and was
completely wrong
so take take and it takes 23 missionary
six look you won we have this loop
deform yeah well okay the computer takes
on before this is of course yeah if this
happens of course I play ninety form I
was more concerned about this which the
engine here doesn't really like it wants
to go f4 when I didn't didn't consider
f4 it is interesting though because of
Knight f5 so there is all this this is
the idea it's just a friggin form ha
I didn't see that listen for
then I should play 94 okay
who's taken on d3 really
why okay I'm kind of fascinated so here
here we need three always sleep so I can
take you why I the background oh my god
all that is silly that's really silly
yeah of course I can take him I was
still thinking here and he goes Quincy
one of course but I can just take care
of course he cannot recapture this is a
background made I was stupid and had two
minutes him okay this is sometimes
informal Matthew it be alternative which
is 365 it's just comfortably better you
sometimes don't look all that hard good
so I mean that that's pretty stupid her
didn't see that one
he actually cannot take the rukon before
so they're only free I like gravity
father is a full pizza let's see okay
and of course then we have the better
angle group t7s better here
I think I can take as the engine
indicates here
[Music]
also thought that there should be three
in the role this is so tough I am sure I
was seen this actually pretty nice
what I get back to defy it
so I'm really grateful okay this way it
was easy I just got upon a g6 helps of
course but the position is already I
think very bad
um instead the engine any kids 94 after
which technically speaking this is a
really really good position I mean I
have low activity here and I always have
94 which is a very good central life
night that is covered and I want the
same blank yeah it seems I will be equal
actually quite quickly as this is a
threat yeah so g6 of course is a blunder
that's two engine is correct but I don't
think avoiding it would have saved the
game yeah it's kind of stupid and I did
not check on d3 yeah I hope you enjoyed
the game thanks for watching